[موسيقى]
30 الف سجين ايراني قتلوا بدم بارد في
مجزره عام
1988 احداث لا تمحو ذكراها المؤلمه السنون
العداله ومحاسبه المسؤولين عن المجزره هما
مطلب وحلم اسر ضحايا المجزره فبعض
العائلات لا تعلم لماذا اعدم احبابهم واين
جثتهم حتى اليوم
[موسيقى]
في المره الاولى التي اعتقلوا فيها شقيقي
لم يكن لديهم اي شيء ضده لذلك اطلقوا
الصراحه في المره الثانيه اعتقلوه ونقلوه
الى سجن سري خاص للتعذيب
وعندما
[موسيقى]
ذهبت امي واختي لرؤيته اصبح شعره الاسود
ابيض بالكامل وفقد كل اسنانه بسبب التعذيب
[موسيقى]
شقيقي في صيف عام
1988 ومعه الاف السجناء السياسيين ولم
تتحقق العداله لهذه الاعدامات ولم نعلم
حتى الان لماذا تم اعدامهم واقصد هنا من
خلال القنوات الرسميه ولم نجد جثته واين
دفن ما زالت هناك كثير من الاسئله حول هذه
المجزره
صوره شقيقي لم تذكرني فقط به بل بكثير من
الاصدقاء والزملاء الذين خسرتهم انها كسره
للقلب لكن بالرغم من ذلك انا على امل ان
هذه الديكتاتوريه لن تستمر وانه لن يستطيع
كسر كل الايرانيين وفي النهايه سيكون
النصر لنا الناس في ايران تستحق الحريه